11 years ago I was a criminal and not
going anywhere read the thank you
economy graduated got my first
internship when I got my first job you
were given these away this is the OG
it's been on my desk every single day
and as of two hours ago I just got
promoted to managing director of my Ad
Agency and none of it would have
happened without it I can't thank you
enough good guy your words can never
never tell you I'm so [__] proud of
you thank you
I did trade attention and build
businesses
[Music]
we're expanding this brand people are
coming into the franchise the game the
game is legit characters resume I'm
excited to look at these videos in 12
years imagine watching videos of
Pokemon's first year I'd watch it every
day and look even how big I dream I
understand what Pokemon is but don't let
me do 50 of Pokemon you know what I mean
then it's still a [__] monster so
really excited how proud are you I don't
know if I'm proud I'm enjoying the
process of building I love that [__]
like I like the bad days in a way that
is so [__] crazy but I know what this
is it's fun to see the evolution
acid trash Pokemon cards yes National
exclusives yes Messi to MLS gas Toronto
gas St Louis trash I'm kidding St Louis
I [__] with you Lamont Jordan Lamont
Jordan
do you understand that Lamont Jordan of
the New York Jets number 34 ran a
touchdown against the Raiders and when
he scored his celebration was to go to
the goal post and act like it was a
chainsaw and he was cutting down a
[__] tree that super gas [__]
Lamont [__] Jordan you went there
yeah that just made my [__] warning
let's go Lamont with the visor then he
went to the Raiders and he was trash
blue that got me going I'm super pumped
I just got a hollow series one one of
one raccoon from this remarkably
handsome young man he will go on to
regret this sale for the rest of his
life it's gonna end up being one of the
worst deals of his career
that's amazing thank you so much what
are you thinking some Gary B's box epic
up there some man is trying to Corner
the [__] garyvee Market Gary be life
I got the Epic garyvee yesterday as soon
as I bought it you're like [__] yeah I
knew it was under praise Gary be epic
whoa yeah it's gone I'm a little bit
upset about that I was upset about that
one
cheers oh
he got a gold wizard two kids are
playing they both know how to play it's
like I gotta see him yeah or hype on
that yeah kids game watch game
[Music]
holy crap get a different card decide
you don't want to sign that one
kids giveaway is gonna be behind here
[Music]
the name New York Jets until someone
[__] up Mark Sanchez Brian Fitzpatrick
Jonathan Vilma Joe Namath Brandon
Marshall Aaron Rodgers Mark Gastineau
Greece Hall James Robinson Michael
Carter the running back Antonio
Cromartie Joe klecco
let's go Brandon Marshall you said
Brandon Marshall already run the film I
[__] won
he said it he said it
so let's keep going okay we'll keep
going the British off Ferguson I love
the brick Nick mangle let's go
guys I have like 400 Jets on the top of
my head I
don't know man yo the next 100 packs are
on dabs
laughs
but it's here in the packs free packs
free packs tap snaps take one and give
them out take one give them out I love
it brother you know how many famous
Gary's are under very rare So when you
came up the game that 89 Brewers rookie
card I was collecting the [__] oh my god
oh I know everything about you oh this
is my best friend Brandon we did shows
together coming up right we had a very
very very famous story between us when
we were 14 where we came up with this
cockamanian game and if you won you
would get a prize and the hottest card
was when you were going crazy when you
got to San Diego yeah and the Upper Deck
rookie card was [__] fire and Brandon
had a bunch of them but everybody took
it from us for like two dollars because
our game was so janky that's really cool
sir is that a funny
the quote of the day is if you live one
[__] life so stop [__] around and
do what you love stop doing it just for
the money because they're all gonna [__]
it up be patient be nice to each other
and get your [__] grind what's next
animation thank you man I love you this
is fun so fun I love it I miss you
already kids listen to me if you're good
enough ain't nobody taking your paper
there's more than enough for every
winning player
what's up Gary what's up Legend the
first baseball card this man bought ever
ever
one of the ways that I take pressure off
of me not failing in front of others is
by reminding people we might love you
harm is reminding people in my circles
that I'm human and I make mistakes thank
you so much you're absolutely the best
bro thank you so much I'm proud of you
11 years ago I was a criminal and not
going anywhere read the thank you
economy graduated got my first
internship when I got my first job you
were giving these away this is the OG
it's been on my desk every single day
and as of two hours ago I just got
promoted to managing director of my Ad
Agency and none of it would have
happened without me I can't thank you no
it's a guy your words can never never
tell you I'm so [__] proud of you
thank you would you sign The Wristband I
would love to it'd be my honor Andy
wait who brought this who brought it
that's nuts wow how old is this
where's trout trouty he needs to see it
call
[Music]
it's for you thank you it's a good one
slap it up this is it for you though
you've been running a gangster ring here
oh
[Music]
I skipped work to be here today I'm glad
you're here don't worry your boss
approved thanks
I worked the nine to five so I come home
I eat I hang out and then it's like from
11 to 4 in the morning I'm back working
and I sleep for four hours and I just
keep that second I don't think I don't
think four hours is the greatest number
everybody's body is a little bit
different but in a week where you feel a
little burnt out it's okay that you
don't do it at all the world's not gonna
stop if you don't go that hard I would
also say working nine to five and only
starting at 11. like I'd rather you
spend a couple more hours on sleep and a
little less time on hanging out
[Music]
one two three three when I put up the
five don't shake my [__] hands
[Music]
garyvee the national what do you think
about my four-year vacation I'm on right
now you mean College yes I think it's
the last time you can actually do that
are your parents paying for it most of
it yeah you should kiss the ground they
walk on that's appreciate that thank you
buddy
good for you
yes you do I mean I'm six years younger
than these kids or older so it's like
and the way you said it is why I know
you're letting age be a variable age has
never had an actual variable on most of
things besides earned wisdom do not have
imposter syndrome or moments of
insecurity just because you're of the
age there's plenty of people 10 years
older than you that don't know half the
[__] you know thank you
my brother I'm gonna hook you up with
this too that's for you my man this is
for you if I do this for you it's for
you darling
you're welcome it's for you and your
brothers
for you guys
have a good show it's for you are you
sure I'm sure thank you you're welcome
brother
my man it's for you
my guy it's for you
is for you
enjoy it man this is so right it's for
you it's good for me
my friend it's for you thank you you're
welcome have a good stuff
because you're swagging bro thank you
you're welcome
what's up brother look at this look at
this t-shirt card magic
want to sell it maybe how much so I
could find now can I give you a really
good piece of spice yeah so most things
don't ever sell that give me at least 10
years on that one it's the [__] logo
you literally have a tattoo of it this
guy's debating selling this when he
actually has the tattoo of it you gotta
keep it awesome all right guys I'll see
you tomorrow I really gotta shut down
day two in the bag by the way completely
am guilted into bringing trash talk back
so making the commitment right now a lot
of comments on that I feel the card
hobby is getting a sense of me out there
a little bit today yes man that's good
it's a good day looking forward to
tomorrow it's [__] Thursday we're
still Friday Saturday Sunday see ya
foreign
[Music]